welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and this is a breakdown for the
trailer of The Last of Us episode 8.
there are only two episodes left and I
cannot wait to find out what new and
interesting ways they find to shatter my
heart into pieces it's not much of it
left and I feel like it's obvious but
there's gonna be spoilers for what we've
seen up until now but I'm not going to
give any future game spoilers whatsoever
until the very end where you will get
ample warning if you haven't played the
game please be careful about going to
the comments if you have played the game
please be careful in the comments
spoil before we get into it a quick
reminder to check out nerdriot.shop
where there's still time to grab our The
Last of Us inspired t-shirt lost in the
darkness we've also released a whole
line of Mandalorian inspired merch just
in time for the season 3 premiere
support the channel and check out all of
our awesome merch options at
nerdright.shop so let's jump in last we
left off in episode 7 Ellie had cemented
her decision to stay with Joel despite
his nasty injury we can see that she's
still taking care of him checking his
forehead to gauge his temperature while
he's out cold since his blood loss is
now under control after being stitched
up and we know how much Joel hates
falling asleep while watching over Ellie
his inability to stay awake more than
likely indicates a fever as a result of
the wound getting infected an infected
wound takes the already high stakes of
the show and just launches them into
space this is a life and death situation
on top of a life and death situation on
top of a life and death situation and in
the next shot we see that Ellie for the
very first time is without Joel and will
have to take the reins of survival into
her own hands and we've been seeing this
progression of Independence throughout
the season at least starts the season
out literally in Chains followed by Joel
kicking her knife away from her then
Joel not allowing her to have a gun to
entrusting her with a pistol of her own
to agreeing that she should have her gun
drawn and be on alert ready for a fight
and now we finally see Ellie being the
one to take care of Joel but as we can
see from the trailer there are plenty of
obstacles standing in her way Last of Us
makes clear that the apocalypse is gross
there are tendrils coming out of mouth
we can hold ourselves to a higher
standard of hygiene thanks to quip quit
makes keeping your mouth healthy easy
quips electric toothbrush has timed
Sonic vibrations with 30 second pulses
to guide a dentist recommended two
minute clean and their water flosser can
give you a gentle or deep clean at the
touch of a button and quips gum starter
kit fits in just about any purse or
pocket for on-the-go Dental Health quip
has a special deal running now for fans
of the last of us but it involves a
tough choice you gotta choose between
Joel and Ellie to cast your vote in the
quipocalypse go to getquip.com infected
once there cast your vote by using
either Joel or Ellie as your promo code
either code will automatically get you
20 off any quick water floss or quip
toothbrush or gum starter kit but if
your favorite character ends up getting
the most votes quick will send you a
special power up to help fight off the
plaque monster which is like a bloater
that lives in your mouth make sure you
get your votes in before midnight on
March 8th we'll announce the winner on
the finale breakdown that's getquip.com
infected and use promo codes Joel or
Ellie to vote for your favorite
character so next it's revealed that
Ellie is pointing gun and David played
by Scott Shepard who you might recognize
as Jean Gray's Father John Gray from
X-Men dark Phoenix with him is James
played by Troy Baker who is the voice
and mocap actor for Joel in the games
David tells you there's room for her in
their group and if I know anything
instead of a man in the woods asks you
to join his group you run I must say it
bears for pets they're pretty cool we
then see a relatively small community
which is clearly not a quarantine Zone
seeing as there are no walls around it
however they seem to have relative
safety and isolation since the
settlement has mountains on one side and
a body of water on the other we then see
three sequential shots that show this
community is heavily influenced by
religion a woman praying David holding
what I presumed to be a Bible and the
community likely listening to David say
a prayer before partaking in their meal
over this James says I don't mean to
question your sense of Mercy David Mercy
being a recurring concept throughout the
Bible and the fact that he voices
hesitance to question David shows that
David is likely one of if not the
highest ranking member of the community
unless we not forget that King David is
an important figure in several religious
texts King David was also famously a
leader of the people and also a Shepherd
so Jill you might want to reconsider
your dream career but that's not all
because James is also a Biblical name
with Saint James being one of Jesus's 12
Apostles and a member of his inner
circle seem familiar and you thought I
was done no because on the right of the
group is Nelson Lees who's listed on
IMDb as the character Josiah like King
Josiah of Judah the connections are
everywhere speaking of connections kind
of a strange coincidence but this is not
the first time Lisa's found himself in a
band of gun wielders scenario seeing as
he played a Trapper in the movie prey
with this oddly similar shot anyway
James saying Ellie's just another mouth
to feed doesn't bode too well for poor
Ellie cutting back to Ellie we see a
continuation of her efforts to defend
and provide for Joel while nursing him
back to health luckily Joel taught her
how to shoot a rifle previously
equipping her with the ability to hunt
while hunting for food she comes across
a deer and we cut to a beautiful
close-up shot at the deer's face which
is gentle and unsuspecting and deer
often symbolize innocence if something
or someone is said to be Delight that
means it has large innocent eyes which
is exactly what we see as Ellie exhales
to study her aim and pull the trigger
the title of the next episode is when we
are in need which we see written on the
banner in the community building but in
Ellie's case she has never been more in
need and seeing her her face flushed and
lips trapped from the harsh elements we
can finish that phrase when we are in
need we must do what it takes to survive
then the rules of predator and prey are
switched as we get an action-packed
sequence of shots showing members of
David's group with their guns at the
ready and Ellie on the run with David
saying the others want to kill you let
me protect you but song goes sideways as
we're then shown David standing in the
same Community Building as before as
seen by the table chairs and chandeliers
but now just a little hotter in the next
shot where Ellie grabs a knife we see
the reflection of the fire in the
background showing she's just as wrapped
up in this whole fire situation we then
see her riding on Horseback and firing a
shot which doesn't phase this guy at all
and it closes with James approaching
something or someone on the ground
suspense so that's where I'm gonna end
the breakdown for those who haven't
played the game and don't want spoilers
this is your warning see you after the
episode well there's Ahoy goodbye okay
for those who are sticking around how
Wild is this episode gonna be I'm on
pins and needles as we know from the
game this is the section where Ellie
runs across David and James while
hunting and David reveals after he and
Ali have to work together to fight off
and escape a horde of infected that it
was Ellie and Joel who killed his men
who he sent to Eastern Colorado
University my guess is they'll probably
skip the horde of infected fight sequins
seeing as they've opted for a
relationship over action in this series
but I'm hoping they keep the chilling
way which David reveals this in photo
Ellie prefacing it with the belief that
everything happens for a reason the
trailer also seems to show that there
will be a much bigger emphasis on the
group's religion than there was in the
game there were bits thrown into the
game that indicated the religious nature
of the group the banner for one but also
the lines David would say in combat like
forgive him Lord and for a second you
shook my faith another thing that wasn't
revealed by the trailer and could
actually be admitted from the show
altogether is the fact that the
community practices cannibalism in the
game whether or not the entire Community
is aware of this is unknown but it seems
from a note you find in the game that
they turn a cannibalism out of necessity
when food was running scarce I would be
pretty surprised if they didn't keep
this in though because it doesn't
effective job of showing yet another
aspect of this post-apocalyptic world I
had to guess we might even get a scene
where David defends his reasoning for
cannibalism through Biblical verses if
they wanted to change it up a bit but
one of the biggest scenes of this
chapter that we see in the episode
trailer is the showdown between Ellie
and David in the burning building which
in the game is called Todd's Steakhouse
whether or not it'll be a steakhouse or
more of a community center or dining
Center in the show has yet to be seen
but either way the set designer did a
great job matching The Wagon Wheel
chandeliers and setting the mood now as
we know this part gets really intense
and seeing as in the season trailer
there was a shot of Joel hugging Ellie
while she's covered in blood I think a
lot of the same Beats from the game will
probably be hit in the show whether or
not they go as psychologically dark
though we'll have to wait and see But be
sure to catch our Sunday night after
show that we do after The Last of Us
airs as well as Eric's breakdowns on the
episodes until then you can follow me on
Twitter at it'sanavanston and follow And
subscribe to new rockstars at new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love and don't forget to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive as well see you next time
[Music]
foreign